in this video we're going to talk about
how to graph piecewise functions so what
does that mean piecewise functions how
do we graph them and I'm going to show
you two easy methods so if you don't
like one you can use the other method so
let's dive in we're going to do three
examples see if you can pause the video
and do some of these on your own if you
want some practice but the first example
we have f of x equals X plus 4 when X is
less than or equal to zero and f of x
equals 2 when X is greater than zero so
let me show you the first method which I
call the graph and erase method so the
graph and erase method f of x is like y
so we're graphing the line Y equals X
plus four okay X plus four this is just
a line with a Y intercept of four so
it's going to cross right here at 4 and
it has a slope of one so that means
we're going to go rise one run one rise
one run one or you can go the other
direction okay
okay and you can see we have this line
here let me just draw a light line
but you see how it says we want the part
of the line where X is less than or
equal to zero so that means when you're
equal to zero or less than so meaning to
zero or to the left this part here we
don't want let's see if we can erase
that
part right there since we don't need it
so it's just going to be this graph
right here
I'm going to draw the arrow it keeps
going to the left equals means that we
want to use this as a closed Circle it
includes that a point or less than to
the left okay now the second equation f
of x or y equals two we know that y
equals 2 is a horizontal line so I could
draw a horizontal line like this
but I just want the part where X is
greater than zero so it means it doesn't
equal here when X is zero just when it's
greater than or to the right now again I
could draw that whole line and erase the
part that I don't want I just want the
part that's to the right of zero okay so
why do they call it a piecewise function
well it passes the vertical line test
meaning for every x value there's only
one y value
and even here see how this is open and
this is closed it's only Crossing once
and it's in pieces you're on this graph
until you get to zero and then you jump
down to here and you're on this graph
now what's method number two method
number two I call the table method
because we're going to make two tables
we're going to make a table when X is
less than or equal to zero so maybe
we'll pick some numbers like 0 negative
one negative two
and then for the second graph we're
going to pick values that were X is
greater than zero now greater than zero
I would still include zero
okay zero one two three but at this
point since it's greater than zero we're
going to draw an open circle and that's
what we did right here see so let's go
ahead and do that so I put 0 in I get 4.
if I put negative 1 and I get 3. if I
put negative 2 and I get 2 and you can
see I'm plotting 0 4 negative 1 3
negative 2 2 and you can see I can draw
a line and I'm going just to the left
since it's less than over here this is
going to be 2 2 2. see X is always equal
to two and you can see when I'm plotting
these points
I'm getting a horizontal line but I just
want the line where it's greater than
but not equal to zero so that's the
table method let's go to number two now
so for number two we have y equals one
half X plus two when X is less than
negative two so this is a line with a Y
intercept of 2 and a slope of one-half
so rise one run two rise one run two or
go the other way down one over two down
one over two down one over two but
notice we want the part where X is less
than negative two so I could draw this
line
but I really only want the part where
it's less than but not equal to negative
2. so this is going to be open
and lastly means to the left so the rest
of this here we're going to erase
okay since we don't need that
okay graph and erase method the second
equation here we have y equals the
square root of x plus 2. now you're
probably familiar with square root
graphs they basically look like like
this but what's happening is this plus 2
is Shifting the graph left two so what
would happen is right here
is where the graph would start
and when let's see when X is let's just
say x is negative one negative one plus
two is one square root of one is one
when X is 2 2 plus 2 is 4 square root of
4 is 2. and you can see this graph is
curving like that it's still a function
it passes that vertical line test see
closed here open here and we just did
the graph and erase method now you can
use the table method again what I would
do is I would pick points like less than
negative 2. now I would include negative
2 negative 4 negative 6. but at negative
2 when I put this in let's see that's
negative 1 plus 2 is 1 but at negative 2
1 I'm looking at an open circle because
it's less than but not equal to right so
you want to include this number even
though it's not equal to just make it
open and pick some numbers that are less
so if I do negative 4 1 half times
negative 4 is negative 2 plus 2 is 0. so
let's see negative 4 0 that's right here
if I do negative 6 that's negative 3
plus 2 is negative one that's going to
be right here and you can see this is a
line going to the left since it's less
than to the left
same thing here with this one we can
make a table I'd start with negative 2
since it's greater than or equal to
negative two and let's pick some other
numbers negative one you could pick
let's say 2 would be a good one and
maybe like uh what's another one maybe
seven so if we put those numbers in
we're going to get 0 1 2 and 3 and then
notice that negative two that's equal to
negative two so we're going to make this
a closed Circle
and you get your graph so sometimes you
know it's just an easy graph you might
want to just graph and erase the part
you don't want sometimes it's an
equation you're not as familiar with and
you might want to use the table method
let's look at one more example okay why
don't you give number three a try on
your own but before you do that I just
want to mention that there's three
unique ways that you can help support
the videos that I'm putting up here on
my Mario's Master tutoring YouTube
channel one is that I've got two video
courses for sale links are in the
description Algebra 1 Algebra 2 a really
great course that I put a lot of time
and energy in Walking you through a
typical Algebra 1 or Algebra 2 slash
college algebra class the other method
is you can join the channel as a
supporting member and you can for a few
dollars a month make a donation to the
channel and it helps support the videos
that I'm putting up here and I see
everyone's name and channel and handle
that comes through that's a supporter
and I really appreciate that and the
Third Way is is if you're interested
I've got a Teespring store and links in
the description I have also some
T-shirts below this video so if you're
interested in purchasing one of my math
t-shirts that's another great way to
help support the work that I'm doing
here for you on YouTube so let's dive
into this last example number three what
would you do on this one well remember
we've got the graph in the erase method
we've got the table method or we could
even do a hybrid where we do one of one
of each right and I think that's what
I'm going to do here because I've got
Y equals X plus 2. I know that's a line
with a Y intercept of 2 right so I could
put a point right here and I know this
has a slope of one which means I'm going
to go rise one run one
rise one run one okay or I can go the
other direction
so I can see that this is a line but I
only want where X is greater than or
equal to negative one so here's negative
1 here equal to negative one or greater
than means you're going to the right
because X values are getting greater
so that's that part there
and now for the second one here I know
that this is a parabola that's opening
down that two is stretching at the
negative makes it reflect and the plus
one shifts it up one so I know it looks
something like that but what I'm going
to do here is I'm just going to make a
table I'm going to pick some values that
are negative 1 or less
okay so plot a few of these so if I put
negative 1 and I get 1 times negative 2
is negative 2 plus 1 is negative 1. now
negative 1 negative 1 this point see how
it says less than negative 1 but not
including negative one so that means
over here at negative one negative one
this has to be an open circle let's do
negative two so negative two squared is
four times negative 2 is negative eight
plus one is negative seven so let's see
negative two negative seven two three
four five six seven that's right about
here and again like I said we knew we
knew it was a parabola opening down so
this graph is going to basically look
like this if we drew the whole thing it
would more look more like that notice
it's still a function passes that
vertical line test it's just in pieces
and you got it so great job if you're
able to get that one if you want to see
more examples and you want to get some
more practice graphing piecewise
functions follow me over to this
previous video that I did on piecewise
functions right there and we'll get some
more practice I'll see you over in that
video